porque aguanto tanto el primer ministro
boris johnson y cuánto le afecto digamos
llegar hasta este punto tensar la cuerda
hasta que ya no pudo más
una explicación es que más se ocupa es
que por ello son su principal prioridad
es el mismo y es de alguna forma lo que
más le importa es poder movilizar sus
propios intereses en ese sentido el
durante mucho tiempo él ha dicho en su
biografía y lo ha dicho en varios puntos
el siempre soñó con ser ministro y por
lo tanto hizo lo que tuvo a mano para
llegar
incluso llegó a apoyar el plan
existiendo que no era un convencido del
tema al principio y ahora y ahora hizo
todo lo que tuvo que hacer y además hay
un tema que históricamente por johnson
80 personas que éticamente no tiene
estándares muy altos y eso está
demostrado su vida personal de su vida
como para como un como alcalde por
ejemplo está el escándalo el millonario
que quiera su ex amante y que además de
obtuvo contratos con con la ciudad de
londres mientras el alcalde así que la
verdad es que él él tiene una tradición
de una persona que vela por sí mismo por
sus propios intereses y que tiene
estándares éticos bajos el punto es que
el partido conservador eligió como su
líder
la ciudadanía los votos como su primer
ministro
o al menos voto el partido como con el
partido gobernante y por lo tanto era
difícil sacarlo a pesar de todo esto
se va a boris johnson definitivamente de
la política británica digamos cuál va a
ser el escenario más próximo del primer
ministro boris johnson que ya anunció
que dejaba su cargo
bueno por ahora hasta que los
parlamentarios de su partido no digan lo
contrario él se mantiene en el puesto
ha nombrado un gabinete de nuevo no es
completo pero pero tiene el andamiaje
suficiente para poder funcionar
en términos estrictos hay regulaciones
respecto a lo que a lo que se llama
izquierda ministro el pre ministro que
simplemente está de custodio del cargo y
en ese sentido él
no tendría por convención la capacidad
de movilizar las reformas políticas muy
profundas pero sí hacerse cargo de las
crisis y en ese sentido por ejemplo el
crisis del costo de la vida del costo de
vida puede diría darle la posibilidad de
implementar reformas tributarias por
ejemplo eso es un tema que es debatible
pero en el fondo es el gran temor que
muchos parlamentarios de su partido
tienen que él se ponga más creativo con
respecto a las políticas públicas no ver
y termine llevando adelante iniciativas
que no corresponden al periodo de
custodios la otra opción es que su
partido lo saque antes y los mecanismos
para ello no son tan claros ni tan
definidos pero ellos están analizando
que tanto javier puede hacer el boris
johnson en este periodo que le queda
hasta que entregue el cargo lo que
sabemos hasta hoy sería en octubre pero
puede ser antes con este escenario que
tenemos que tanto podría ser boris
johnson o ya lo mejor que tan dilatada
puede ser el proceso jurídico en reino
unido como para llevar adelante un plano
o alguna ley o algún cambio que quiera
hacer de inmediato porque ya no queda
nada de tiempo
la verdad es que lo que puede hacer es
poco en términos regulatorios pero el
problema la particularidad del reino
unido es que gran parte de lo que
nosotros llamamos regulaciones son
convenciones son simplemente acuerdos o
tradiciones que se han llevado adelante
de una forma en este caso el manual del
gabinete que se creó el 2011 con
objetivo de la coalición entre los
buenos entre los conservadores y los
liberaldemócratas se creó un manual que
rige todo tipo de este tipo de
situaciones pero un manual que por
cierto no es una ley y cuando boris
johnson puede pasar por alto y este
manual lo que dice es que efectivamente
él tiene una capacidad limitada y
adelante políticas públicas pero como se
planteaba con la excusa de la crisis que
está específicamente mencionada en el
manual podría saltarse alguna vez de
restricciones sin embargo también por
ellos no tiene una fama de ser alguien
que se sienta muy amarrado por las
normas y vive las convenciones y por lo
tanto
él podía perfectamente llegar a tratar
de movilizar algunas cosas e
independiente es decir están permitidas
o no por este manual en este caso es su
propio partido el que va a tener que
saber cómo pararlo votando en contra en
el parlamento si no él puede llevar
adelante cualquier tipo de propuesta que
quiera